Carrie is with us in Florida hi Carrie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi how
are you today better than I deserve
what's up so I am currently 20 years old
and I am working and going to school at
the same time and I'm set to graduate in
2023 I'm currently on baby step number
two and I'm just looking ahead at baby
step 3 and baby step 4 and I feel a
quick question regarding baby step
number four so I will be able to go into
a career field once I graduate from
college and get into an actual career
field that will allow me to retire a bit
earlier than the average age and if I'm
understanding correctly you invest in a
401k and a Roth IRA but you have to be a
certain age before you can pull that out
for retirement so if there's anything
available what would be the best option
in addition to a 401k and a Roth IRA to
start investing in so that if I retire
say between ages 45 and 50 I can pull
that money out and use it
penalty-free hmm very good question
you're really thinking ahead you're
gonna do well well to start with I would
not bother with the secondary investing
until you until you get a little bit
older a little bit further in your
career because you've got plenty of time
to do that so for now we'll go on up to
baby step four and use your 401k and
your Roth IRA and let that stuff let
those beginning investments be growing
tax deferred tax free that's going to be
much more important then let's say you
look up and you said you were talking
about retiring at 45 or 50 right yeah
okay so if you looked up and you were 30
that would still give you 15 years to
invest okay so if this question still
dinging around in your head at 30 you're
a hundred percent debt-free by then
you've got an emergency fund you've got
a chunk of money because you will have
been investing in your 401k for you know
8 10 years by then at 15% you'll have
your house paid off or be getting close
I mean you're going to be
really rockin the way you're thinking
here okay so you look up at 30 or even
35 years old and this question still
presents itself then you would just
simply start investing in non retirement
mutual funds and that we call that
bridge investing now more likely what
the question I usually give the way I
usually get this question poised or
posed is you know Dave I think I'm gonna
retire it you know 55 instead of 59 and
I'll need some money for those four
years okay now if you're gonna retire at
45 years old I'll give you a prediction
you're gonna do something else you're
not gonna sit on the dock and fish or do
nothing for the next 50 years that's
very unlikely it's very unusual that you
would be that unproductive with your
life there's not much joy in being that
unproductive okay so but be putting
yourself in a financial position that
you have choices to do whatever without
having to be penalized with a retirement
plan it's still the same question and it
still says I need some mutual funds and
so what I would do at 30 or 35 years old
is I might dial back how much I'm
putting into 401 case because you got a
really really good start on it and crank
up what you're putting in just non 401k
mutual funds and just let them grow and
you could look up and have two or three
million in your 401ks and maybe a
million in your non 401ks by the time
you got to 50 years old pretty easily
with what we're describing and of course
it depends on your income and how much
you invest to create all of that but
those are very doable numbers and you
could get there without a doubt so hey
thank you for joining us